this video was brought to you by
manscaped so you're a young guy growing
up in the very strict and rigid society
of japan
a society that values the family more
than the individual
a society with an extremely competitive
school system where not having a steady
job or not being part of an upstanding
family
figuratively and literally can ruin your
life and make you a forever outcast
you happen to have none of those things
maybe you live alone
lost one or both of your parents dropped
out of school and now no one wants to
hire you
it seems like the entire country looks
at you as subhuman
so it looks like you're gonna have to
spend the rest of your life as an
outcast
but then you come across the yakuza
japan's organized crime syndicates
although they're looked down upon they
all happen to be social outcasts just
like you
they offer structure or surrogate family
a way for you to climb up the ranks of
society albeit in a more nefarious way
successful gangsters are able to provide
their kids with a first class
upbringing and much like other organized
crime groups around the world like the
mafia
being a yakuza means that the same
society that looked down upon you would
now have to bow down to you
in fear and submission so yakuza here we
come
when do i get my full body tattoo wait
wait hold on a sec
if you think that you're just gonna jump
into this world and start living the
stereotypical gangster life but with
samurai swords and cutting off fingers
etc
you're gonna be sadly mistaken today's
yakuza are far from the romanticized
yakuza you see in movies
sure a ton of that still goes on but
today's yakuza have grown much more
sophisticated
instead of just gangsters the smart ones
are now economic gangsters or keizai
yakuza
instead of your typical rackets like
extortion gambling drug dealing which
still very much happens
they've catapulted themselves into the
world of high finance legitimate
businesses the stock market real estate
investments multinational corporations
think of the modern day yakuza as a
giant hedge fund with over a hundred
billion dollars to play with
they're involved in virtually every sort
of activity an investment bank or
security firm does
investing in startups mergers and
acquisitions ipos
forks trading distressed companies and
real estate with the more nefarious
activities never far behind
they're held by japan's top
professionals accountants lawyers
financial advisors all wanting a piece
of that yakuza money
it's so bad that crime experts call it
the criminal services industry
they also have some very substantial
political power with even their own
offices that were open as late as 2017.
even though japan has more than enough
anti-racketeering and money laundering
statues
to go around the yakuza have a
remarkable love and hate relationship
with the public
not really found in any other gangs
around the world the general consensus
is that if they don't cause chaos the
japanese people would leave them alone
and average people will sometimes even
do business with them
this is the new yakuza you'll be
entering and if you want to make it out
on top if you want to make it out live
you're gonna have to understand the
economics of the yakuza
the hardest thing for westerners to
understand is that the yakuza are
generally accepted by society
and are even viewed as a somewhat
quasi-legitimate organization
we'll go deeper into this later but it's
because of the deep history and
relationship with japan
because of their acceptance or tolerance
by society the yakuza have been able to
grow
almost unchecked and touch virtually
every single corner of japanese life
that's why the yakuza have over a
hundred thousand members and associates
worldwide
since organized crime is looked at as
something to be exterminated in the u.s
the american mafia purposely kept only
around 5 000 official members at their
height to stay within the shadows with
many more associates around the country
and in this video we're mainly going to
focus on the biggest yakuza family
the legendary yamaguchi gumi which
boasts around 55 000 gangsters divided
into 850 clans accounting for half of
all yakuza
there are other crime families that vary
in some ways but they mostly pale in
comparison to the yamaguchi gumi which
is practically a household name in japan
there are a lot of yakuza back in the
day that cared about things like honor
chivalry and view themselves as modern
day samurai but at the end of the day
the organization's only purpose is to
make money
and make money they do on top of the
more sophisticated rackets they have
going on that we mentioned earlier the
yakuza basically do business in
everything japanese people want but
can't get
think about them as sort of a department
store for the underworld as one cop put
it
from 1978 to 1982 the yakuza families
controlled over 24 000 legitimate
businesses
they control the ports construction jobs
they do what's called labor brokering
where they gather up otherwise
useless uneducated men and sell them as
cheap docile labor
they have a long-standing monopoly on
street style operators and peddlers
which each make around a thousand
dollars per day
they control a lava illegal and legal
gambling they openly host political
parties for candidates that they work
with some of them even work as aids on
their political campaigns they have
interest in professional sports like
boxing sumo wrestling western wrestling
they have interest in the entertainment
business with around 100 or so
production companies talent agencies
booking first movie studios
while of course being involved in all
the typical rackets like loan sharking
collecting protection money from local
businesses running nightclubs and
brothels
with one of their biggest moneymakers of
all time being selling meth
but if you thought that was it you're
sadly mistaken because there are plenty
of more ways that yakuza make money
sex trafficking is a big one public
construction projects like subways and
airports rigging baseball games horse
races
auctions season control of private
hospitals english schools amusement
halls counterfeiting money and other
goods
waste disposal offering security
services smuggling guns into the country
which is a very profitable one
and much much more as one expert put it
the yamaguchi had perfected the art of
converting violence
into money and behind this very
well-oiled machine
is a very strict organizational
structure that reflects the very same
rigid structure of japanese culture
the yamaguchi gumi is structured kind of
like the american mafia with some key
differences and a lot more moving parts
it's a very centralized pyramid
structure that acts very much like a
corporation
there's a dedicated godfather or ceo at
the top with around 850 clans at the
bottom
in the case of the yamaguchi-gumi the
most famous boss was kazu tauka
nicknamed the japanese godfather or
japan's version of the boss of all
bosses
taoka was the third boss of the family
and was known for being very innovative
to keep up with japan's rapidly changing
economy
while also keeping the traditions that
made the yakuza what it was
one of the main differences between the
yakuza and other crime organizations
like the mafia is the oya bunkuben
relationship
which literally translates to father
world child world the oyobin is the
father figure and the koben's only
parents they offer advice help
protection guidance and in return the
kobun or child
gives unwavering loyalty back to the
father
there's nothing really like this in the
west think of it as an extreme
mentor-mentee relationship where you're
formally initiated into a literal new
family
if your oyoban asks you to cross a busy
street you'll enthusiastically do it
without thinking twice
kobans are the ones that stand at the
front of the firing line risking their
own lives first and even taking the fall
for crimes
the oyo ben copeland relationship isn't
just a yakuza thing either
even though they're the ones that take
it the most seriously it was a
reflection of japanese culture at the
time and still prevalent today
there are only been koban relationships
for teachers and oppresses
lords and vassals bosses and followers
and in the yakuza the godfather is the
ultimate surrogate father figure that
guides the way for those
poor lost social outcasts the godfather
is part of the upper management that
make all the big decisions just like a
corporation
below the godfather of four younger
brothers of the godfather or shate
along with eight young assistant
directors are wakashira hosa with one of
those directors
assigned as the young leader or
wakashira and the rest of the upper
management is made up of six senior
consultants which resemble the mafia's
consulate aries if you watch our video
on the american mafia
and then there's the grunts of the
syndicate that do all the dirty work and
run all the gang's different money
making
operations there's one ceo executive
type figure called the kiambu atsukai
and then there's 82 young men or
captains called wakashu that each run
their own gang or clan of children
called ko
boon or enlisted men called kumi in at
the very bottom are apprentices and
people that are loosely associated with
the gang that make up the rest
and the oyuman koben father child
relationship is present from the bottom
of the pyramid all the way to the top
maybe your crew's captain is your oyobun
with you still viewing the godfather as
the ultimate oyubun
so now you know how your new family is
structured let's follow the money from
the bottom up to see what kind of salary
your new profession is going to bring
you
where is the money
by the time our japanese godfather died
in 1981 the yamaguchi gumi was bringing
in well over 460 million dollars
annually or over 1.3 billion dollars in
today's money
because the yakuza are so integrated
into society they're very open about
their numbers to researchers and the
press
making the yakuza one of the most well
researched syndicates out there
and like corporations the major gangs
and upper management even issue annual
financial reports
thanks to an interview with the boss in
1984 starting at the bottom a typical
yakuza soldier will only make around
twenty seven thousand dollars per year
about the same as the average salary
worker in japan medium ranked bosses
will make around a hundred thirty
thousand dollars per year
and godfathers will make around four
hundred thousand dollars per year or
around a million dollars in today's
money
but it all comes down to how many men
you have under you the more men you have
under your syndicate the more business
you're able to conduct and all that
money moves up the chain of command with
the majority of it going straight to you
now you may be saying to yourself but
jake only 27 thousand dollars starting
out
why don't i just get a regular job well
as we mentioned earlier if you weren't a
social outcast and could get a job
you probably wouldn't be thinking about
joining the yakuza and besides treat
this as a learning period an
internship as you learn the culture the
norms how to move up the ranks and
ultimately how to make the family more
money
because if you want to make more money
for yourself you have to provide
more money speaking of the rules the
culture the norms
let's cover that next
[Music]
like other criminal organizations that
yakuza has some very unwritten rules
that must be followed or else you're
going to face some very dire
consequences
coincidentally even though all the major
crime syndicates form independently
across the globe
they all clustered around pretty much
the same rules number one
never reveal the secrets of the yakuza
number two never violate the wife or
children of other members
number three no narcotics with the
exception of the yamaguchi gumi
number four know withholding money from
the family number five always be
obedient to your superiors
and number six don't appeal to the
police or the law if you make a bad but
not the end of the world offense this is
where finger cutting comes in
this practice dates all the way back to
the sword fighting days of feudal japan
the first offense you would cut your
pinky finger at the first joint with a
traditional tonto knife
you'd then wrap it up in a cloth and
present it to your boss
in sword fighting your pinky provides a
lot of strength to your sword
so cutting off your pinky makes you rely
more on your boss for protection
ideally making you more obedient to him
after the first offense you'll cut the
next joint of your pinky off and then
you move on to the next finger
many bosses will preserve the cut
fingers and jars to show the gang what
will happen
if you disobey for worse offenses you'll
cut off your finger and be exiled from
the gang and other gangs as well
and maybe throw in some murders here and
there for really bad offenses
interestingly finger cutting has
increased since the feudal times with a
whopping 45 percent of modern yakuza
members having several fingers in 1993.
and of course we can't talk about the
yakuza without talking about their
trademark tattoos
tattoos date back to the feudal era
where authorities would use them to mark
outlaws and ostracize them from society
the elaborate artistic designs date back
even further as early as the 3rd century
and as society viewed tattoos as more
and more taboo
our outcast yakuza embraced it as a
self-inflicted wound that would forever
distinguish them from the world that
shunned them out
traditional tattoos are also extremely
painful the artist uses a stick with a
bunch of needles at the end
and hammers the ink into your skin a
full back tattoo alone can take as much
as 100 hours
that's why the yakuza also viewed
tattoos as a sign of toughness and
masculinity the more tattooed they are
the more pain they had to endure
although yakuza are settling for more
modern tattooing techniques these days
some still do it to earn that badge of
honor
[Music]
but the question still remains japan is
known to have the best cops and a very
low crime rate
so how are over a hundred thousand
gangsters able to thrive
why do police notify yakuza before a
raid so they have time to hide the
contraband
and escape why are gangs able to hold
press conferences to apologize to the
public and police for the turf wars
without getting arrested on the spot
to understand this we have to travel
back in time to fetal japan
back in fido japan the bosses of
construction projects needed a lot of
workers surfs to do the grunt work
that labor cost a fair amount of money
so these bosses hire gamblers to gamble
with their construction workers to win
the boss's money back
while taking a cut you have to admit
that's pretty clever
these gamblers got together into bands
to help each other out and for the basis
of organized crime in japan
along with many of the traditions we
talked about earlier finger cutting
tattoos the word yakuza and the
long-standing business of gambling
asians love
gambling these gangs started working
with authorities early on and started
the tradition of government corruption
these gangs were kind of like an
underworld mutual aid society they
helped out fellow traveling gamblers
which grew into the folklore of the
compassionate yakuza outlaw
outlaws that society had no use for but
who stood up for the common man
this was also the era of the samurai
which the yakuza identified with today
as japan ended feudalism with democracy
and industry
these yakuza gangs adjusted to the
modernizing economy this is when we got
a lot of the basic rackets we see today
labor brokering controlling streetcars
legitimate business friends and when
they started paying off police
and with the introduction of democracy
the yakuza viewed it as a threat to
their way of life and business
so they naturally align themselves with
the far-right politicians called the
ultra-nationalists
this extreme group wanted to go back to
the feudal ways of worshiping the
emperor and war alerts and oppose
everything democratic socialists or
communists the yakuza served as
political muscle assassins bodyguards
intimidating voters and were so
integrated with the ultra nationalists
that even today it's hard to tell them
apart at times
and everything leading up to this point
has contributed to why the yakuza is
viewed as a somewhat legitimate part of
society
they met the need of people wanting to
gamble they were heavily involved with
the economy as they started modernizing
and the government has always worked
with them to some extent since the old
days
by the end of world war ii japan was
occupied by the us and put
all their energy into skyrocketing the
economy more economic
change meant more ways for the yakuza to
make money and from there it started
consolidating into bigger and bigger
families including the yamaguchi gumi
as the country started to prosper so did
the gangs by transitioning from
controlling necessities to controlling
the luxuries we talked about earlier
drugs prostitution entertainment etc
they also started getting more violent
and continued to dig their teeth deeper
and deeper into politics
the yakuza helped make or break
politicians careers and in return
they got political access and favors
this is the period where the yakuza made
what i call their seed money
the money that will be needed for them
to go international and turn them into
economic gangsters later on
that happened in the 60s and 70s when
the yakuza started expanding all over
asia and in pretty much every nation
where there were business opportunities
with a focus on the mef and sex trade
however the golden years of the yakuza
were right around the corner with the
great bubble economy of japan
from 1986 to 1991. by now the yakuza
were already sitting on piles and piles
of cash and as the economy skyrocketed
they basically threw their money into
every single possible investment
legitimate corporations real estate
stocks etc after the bubble burst the
money stopped coming in
countless of scandals came out showing
how entangled they were with society and
they had to go back to the basics with
handling bankruptcy cases public work
contracts etc
and through all this because of the
history of the yakuza the police realize
that they're never gonna get rid of
organized crime
and that maybe just maybe it's better to
contain organized crime instead of
putting up with unorganized crime
which brings us to today the old yakuza
are fading out and the new generation
are much more violent
they care less about chivalry honor
traditions and only really care about
money
they came out of the bubble with assets
and priceless business experience
but not all is well in the yakuza world
the open violence seems to be slowly
breaking down the harmony they once had
with the public
but not all is lost from the end of
feudalism to today
the yakuza have managed to become one of
the most sophisticated international
crime syndicates in the world they've
grown the last 300 years and as long as
there's a list of profits to be made
they'll probably be here for another
300.
[Music]
so if you're gonna join the yakuza
you're probably gonna want to get your
own full body tattoo to show off your
strength and to fit in with your new
family
to get tattooed you're gonna need to get
rid of all that disgusting hair on your
body and below your waist
yes some yakuza even get tattooed down
there don't ask me how
this is where manscape comes in the new
perfect package 3.0 manscaping kit makes
trimming off all that disgusting body
hair safe and easy without running into
painful nicks and cuts down there
this is thanks to their new lawnmower
3.0 waterproof body trimmer it features
their advanced skin safe technology
anti-tug adjustable trimmer guards
replaceable ceramic trimmer blades a
7000 rpm motor with their quiet stroke
technology a 600 milliamp hour battery
that charges via usb
and a very convenient built-in led light
for closer more precise trimming and you
can get 20
off and free shipping when you use the
code tran 20 with your perfect package
3.0 purchase with the link below
or at manscape.com so confidently clean
yourself up down there and support the
brands that help make mini documentaries
like this one possible
again that's 20 off and free shipping
with the code tran 20 with the link
below
if you are still watching this right now
do me a quick favor go in the comments
below and just write out i watch to the
very end
and click send it will give the youtube
algorithm a nice little boost and it
really does help out a ton
and for crying out loud if you're all
the way through this video and you're
still not subscribed
what the heck you get free videos like
this every single week that you can
dislike and
unsubscribe from whenever you want so
yeah subscribe
and notification bell below when i was
researching this video literally every
single documentary all they talked about
were the tattoos i mean the tattoos are
cool and all
but like there's a lot more to it so i
hope that this
little mini documentary did it for you
guys you learn about the yakuza if you
guys haven't checked out our video on
the american mafia you can check that
out
it'll be on the end card after this
little sequence and
like link below and as you can tell i'm
pretty tired and my voice is very tired
from talking this whole time
so yeah thank you so much for watching i
really do appreciate it you can follow
me on instagram by the way at
jaketrend.io
for like memes and like me ranting about
stuff or
behind the scenes stuff you can follow
me on jaketrend.io thank you so much for
watching
i'm gonna go eat and like take a break
and i will see you guys in the next one
you've been awesome
[Music]
you